Find the place value
of 3 in 4,356.
Now, whenever I think about
place value, and the more you
do practice problems on this
it'll become a little bit of
second nature, but whenever I
see a problem like this, I
like to expand out what 4,356
really is, so let me rewrite
the number.
So if I were to write it--
and I'll write it
in different colors.
So 4,356 is equal to--
and just think about
how I just said it.
It is equal to 4,000 plus
300 plus 50 plus 6.
And you could come up with that
just based on how we said
it: four thousand, three
hundred, and fifty-six.
Now another way to think about
this is this is just like
saying this is 4 thousands
plus-- or you could even think
of "and"-- so plus 3 hundreds
plus 50, you could think of it
as 5 tens plus 6.
And instead of 6, we could
say plus 6 ones.
And so if we go back to the
original number 4,356, this is
the same thing as 4--
I'll write it down.
Let me see how well I can-- I'll
write it up like this.
This is the same thing is 4
thousands, 3 hundreds, 5 tens
and then 6 ones.
So when they ask what is the
place value of 3 into 4,356,
we're concerned with
this 3 right here,
and it's place value.
It's in the hundreds place.
If there was a 4 here, that
would mean we're dealing with
4 hundreds.
If there's a 5, 5 hundreds.
It's the third from the right.
This is the ones place.
That's 6 ones, 5 tens,
3 hundreds.
So the answer here is it is
in the hundreds place.